[Music]
with a tight job market and Rising labor
costs many companies getting an early
start when it comes to seasonal help
Mary Jane beliesza shares the hiring
efforts from local and National
employers
it's peak season for Huntington Jewelers
with the new location in Summerlin and
many holiday events planned CEO Chris
calari is already looking for seasonal
help we've hired two seasonal people
right now and they're great we have
their great attitudes and we like the
fact that they're with us they're great
additions to our team and like I said we
hope that they stay with us a long time
caleri says it's not just about finding
workers but the right fit to help their
family business grow we are like a
little family here but we also have to
get the job done and we have to put the
experiences that the customers expect
when they come to Huntington Jewelers
Huntington Jewelers isn't the only
business getting a head start many Big
Chain companies are looking to hire now
some employers will wait till mid
November to start beefing up of course
for Christmas and the holidays and
things like that but some of the
employers like UPS Amazon we've noticed
that they've already started hiring for
their seasonal positions Marcel Sneed is
with Dieter as part of employee Nevada
business Hub they help people find jobs
as well as helping employers fill
positions and people are doing more
online shopping now than before and a
lot of stores are not going to be open
for Thanksgiving as traditionally they
were Snead says there has been an
increase of companies offering
incentives like pay increases and
bonuses we've noticed that some
employers are not putting seasonal on
their job descriptions they're just
hiring they want part-time or full-time
workers and of course the goal is to
retain you on after the holidays with
the free Job Fair coming up next month
Sneed is encouraging everyone to attend
now more than ever is the perfect time
for everyone to look for work
the fall job fair takes place Thursday
November 17th at the Sahara West library
from 10 to 3. a number of employers
including MGM Resorts Amazon USPS United
Health Group are hiring just to name a
few